guys we're doing a little QA here you
guys submitted your questions on or TV
and on Twitter and here we go Solomon
Hatcher asks what did you think of
President Obama's oval office address
regarding the San Bernardino shooting
and the American response to Isis I
thought the his speech was actually it
was kind of depressing it struck me as
very depressing and he seemed kind of
exhausted and sad I don't know that we
really have a plan yet I hope that we do
but there were in this very weird place
right now if you watch my direct message
from from last week you'll you'll see my
thoughts we're in this weird place where
everyone's sort of afraid but not sure
what to do and I just hope that that
doesn't lead us all to splintering
against each other and letting the bad
voices take hold so as for our response
it doesn't seem like we really have a
response I was happy that he said that
he'd like to get congressional
authorization it would be nice if we had
that for wars these days at serious riri
on twitter s do you celebrate Hanukkah
why or why not I always feel atheists
should ask themselves these things yeah
i mean i don't believe that there's some
magic sky god who's watching me and
doing these things but as I've said
before I'm Jewish the way in Italian
person's Italian or Greek person's Greek
so yeah these are just some traditions
basically for me so yeah I lit some
candles gave some gifs got some good
stuff all right at run 7 said you keep
talking about regressives but you never
take on the fact that Otis president
nited states and John Kerry are extreme
regressive what is your take on this and
what would you say to people saying
Obama allowed a great deal of US foreign
policy to regress you know the John
Kerry one's interesting because if you
heard a couple weeks ago he sort of
excused the Charlie Hebdo shooting
saying that well they sort of had a
reason to kind of do that that's as
regressive as you can possibly get it
sort of slid under the radar with the
media as far as Obama you know look we
do play in all these identity politics
things and I think he does add to that
being the president is not easy but I
don't think I don't think he's a
regressive in the worst sense of it but
yeah I think in general our politicians
should try to do better at Stephen G
Hubbard asked what do you think of Sam
Harris's idea that we shouldn't label
ourselves atheists because it gives
theocrats something to fight against is
atheist an important part of your self
identity you know I never even identify
it as an atheist or even said it i'm
pretty sure that the first time I
actually ever said it was on this show
when I was talking to Milan opolis it's
it's irrelevant I don't base my I base
my thoughts and my feelings on what's
going on in my brain and that's pretty
much it so you know atheists there's no
doctrine this is the irony of all these
people especially the regressives that
keep taking the atheists say there are
new atheists new atheists are just
atheists who are speaking up there's no
doctrine that would link atheists
together other than they generally don't
believe in God or awaiting for some
evidence for it so I don't think it's
that important to label it and I think
the reason they're trying to label it so
much is because they're trying to pin a
lot of problems on us at TK 421 asked
who influenced you the most politically
who if anybody inspired your liberalism
you know I come from the comedy world so
I'd say you know Bill Maher George
Carlin probably more than anybody else
and the the interesting thing about
George is that he really people didn't
know about his politics / say except
that he just thought that the whole
system was warped and corrupt which I
completely believe I try to talk about
things within the system so that we can
hopefully make them better but I would
say those two on the comedy side of
things were my two biggest influences at
gap would worth on a weekly basis how
many times do you get called a racist
bigot etc for your apostasy you know
fortunately because I think we've built
something really good here I get a
pretty like long leash even on social
media that I don't get called that stuff
that often however since we've started
doing this show and I'm talking about
this stuff more I have lost several
friends several at this point a couple
weeks ago it was probably too now I've
lost a couple more I've had people that
I know the people that know me really
well call me bigoted and all kinds of
awful things I've seen some of the
tactics that I always talk about being
used on other people now being used on
me so it just sort of sucks but if
anything it makes me
double down more and you know want to do
the right thing more so they're not
going to they're not going to beat me at
captain's stack do you think there is a
clear line between completely uncensored
discourse and completely censored speech
how can we judge how sensitive we should
be without lobotomizing our ideas I mean
I would basically say that because I'm a
free speech absolutist you could say
anything you can absolutely say anything
yeah you should not instigate people
into violence and should not be pushing
violence and pushing people to want to
do violent acts but beyond that say
whatever you want and then have the
battle of ideas that's what we need to
have more of here instead of just
running to safe spaces and having
trigger warnings and all of that
nonsense because guess what these kids
that are in college now they're doing
that they're going to get into the real
world and that [ __ ] doesn't exist in the
real world and then we're going to have
a whole generation of people that are
going to come up at the same time
believing of that stuff in its pure
nonsense and finally at corpsman what's
your favorite gay sex position that
would be the reverse wookie alright guys
thanks for playing along and you can use
hashtag ask dave rubin on the twitter
you